サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
えーと 今日のテーマに入る前に
一応これは皆様にね ブッダの教えを紹介する説法という感じになりますので
あのお布施の中で法説というね
真理を知ることは一番徳の高い最高なお布施であると釈尊に説かれております
今日のこの説法会できたのは
この戸田千晶さんがこのそこら辺に住んでいる方ですけど
ホールの費用をお布施していただきました
だからこの今日 講演会はこの戸田千秋さんのお布施で行いますので
彼女と家族の方々に 親戚の方々に仏法僧のお守りがありますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
早くも心清らかになって悟りの光が現れますようにと誓願いたします
皆様もこのお布施 寄付ごとも大変功徳になりますから
我々の人生も幸福になりますようにと祈願を垂れて話を聞いてください
えーと 今日のテーマは立ち止まらずもう一歩前ということで
勇気を出して概念を手放せというテーマなんですけども
実は うーん いや 私もわからないんですね
このテーマを作った 作られた方々は
作った方々はあの何を言いたかったかということをよくわからなくて
自分勝手な考えで講演
昨日結構悩んでいたんですね
これ何をしゃべればいいかいいかというね
ことで まあ一応 お釈迦様の立場のいくつかのポイントを今日紹介したいと思います
で この概念についてのお釈迦様の経典にいくつかあります
これが頭の中に入り込んじゃって
もうわけもわからない状態でありましたからね
もうかなり膨大なテーマになりかねませんので
そこを忘れて経典はできるだけではなくて
今日は引用しないことにして話を進めます
引用しちゃうと もうかなり大変な
世界になってしまうんです
そういうわけで では今日は概念について学ぶということになります
眼耳鼻舌身意に入る色声味触法という情報データを頭の中で理解した結果は概念です
まあ簡単ですね 我々は生きていると言っても
生きているということは変なことなんですね
外からいろんなデータを取り入れて
そこを処理するんですね
それが生きていることなんですね
だから例えばね 鉛筆は生きているかというと生きてないんですね
何もデータ取り入れて
それに対する反応してないんだからね
だから生き物っていうのは
眼耳鼻舌身意と人間には 6つついてますけど
6つもついてない生物もいますけどね
しかし  この体と心からデータを取り入れて反応する
取り入れて反応する それが生きることなんです
すごいシンプルなんです
わからないものでも 不可思議なものでも何でもないんです
この世の中で至って簡単なことなんで
生きるということはね
いわゆる理解することね
ただこの肉体がね 眼耳鼻舌身意データを受けてよってから反応する
それだけ 例えばお腹がすいたということは
肉体が何か感じているんですね
感じたらそれに反応する
反応は食べることなんですね
食べることになったら
またいっぱいいろんな反応しなくちゃいけない
何を食べようかとかね
食べるものをどうやって手に入るようにするのかとか
どんな食べ方にするのかとか
いろんな反応が起きてやっているんです
だから簡単に見れば 肉体が眼耳鼻舌身から受けた情報に反応する
それだけなんです このまず眼耳鼻舌身からデータが受けたら
これは何なのかとパッと決めるんですね
それが概念ということなんです
目に何か入った瞬間で概念が生まれているので
それはもう必ず生まれる
避けられません 理解が正しいか否かは関係がありません
だから私の目が見たものが正しいんですか？間違ってるか
これじゃないんです 目が開けたら入ったデータが入ったらもう概念が生まれた
お釈迦様が言うのは 青い
赤 黄色のような大きい小さいって
大きい小さい ちょっと判断ですけどね
そんな感じでさっと入っちゃうんですね
それが正しいですか？間違ってる
そんなことじゃないんですね
だから生きているならば
データが触れて反応する
それはもう基本的で どうすることもできないプログラムですね
ではデータ見せました
この黒い文字で 読める方がいらっしゃいますか？いると思いますけどね
読み方ご存知方がいるならば
私は読めません これギリシャ文字ですけど
ん はい という単語を理解できますか？何かの概念が現れますか？私は意図的に皆様にわからない単語を入れたんです
わからない 自分勝手に決めたものですけどね
わかってる方々もおそらくいるだろうと思いますけど
で たくさんの方々にわからないと思いますね
でも あの黒い文字の書いてる単語
見たら概念が生まれないと思う
生まれているんです 必ず概念が現れているはずです
これは何ですかという自問してみたら
起きた概念を発見することができます
だから自分が概念が生まれたんだけど
わからないでしょ だってあっという間に
ナノ秒で言えば おそらくまあ 60 70 ナノ秒でもう概念が生まれているんです
60 70 って言ったのは
この光のあれ行くためにも時間かかりますからね
7 秒で 7 秒では起こりません
ここに当たった光が皆さんの目に入って
目から脳まで行くためには
だいたい 57 秒  77 秒はかかっているんです
その間でもう概念が生まれたんですね
しかし わからないでしょ
じゃあ次に自分で言葉で質問してください
あれって何？と あれって何？と自分で聞いたら答えが出てくるでしょ
それが概念なんです だからあの黒い文字はね
まあプロやってるんですけど
まあまあ 黒い文字を見て
あれ何ですかね？と言ったら
各人によっていろいろ
一部の方々は あれはギリシャ文字だとも知っている方もいるかもしれません
ギリシャ語を知っている方だったらもう読まれているかも
意味もわかっているかも
まるっきりギリシャ語を知らない方は
まあ全然別な なんだあれはという概念が生まれてくる
数学とかを知っている人ならば
まあやっぱ数学で使っているあれでしょ
だからそこら辺でなんとか
で パイとかありますからね
皆さんは小文字のパイで
これ大文字のパイなんですね
だからこの まあいいんです
とにかく概念が生まれたんです
だから見るものは知ってる必要ないんです
生まれて初めて目に入るものには概念が生まれる
次の概念と言葉の関係
概念に言葉のラベルを貼って整理することができます
そこで概念にそれから言葉をつけたりするんですね
言葉を使える生命はそのようにしています
この言葉を使うことによって
概念は一束一束分類カテゴリーに分けちゃって
いろいろ整理整頓できます
言葉を使わない人々や生命にとっては分類できないんですね
と我々は勝手に思っているだけで
それでも何かしら分類はしています
しかし 言葉にならない概念もあります
はい この私が書いている順番で皆様も考えていくならば
私が言っているポイントはわかると思います
目が開けた瞬間で 耳に音が触れた瞬間で概念が生まれている
犬猫にも変わりはありません
耳がある生命にとっては
音が触れた途端 概念が生まれる
目の目がある 生命に すべての生命に何か目に触れた途端
概念が生まれている 言葉現れるかないか
別な話で その中で言葉という道具を使っている我々人間にとっては
概念 言葉というラベルを束を持ってパチパチと概念にラベルを貼って整理整頓する
そこで皆様にはラベルを貼らない単語を出しました
なんで出したのかというと
まあ言葉なくても概念が生まれるということを言うために
それで我々はの気持ち
すべて言葉で表せますかね
我々の経験一切言葉にして語れますかね
語れませんね ということは
概念は無数に無限にある
言葉っていうのはすごい少ないんです
だから言葉で表せない概念
気持ちって大量にあるんです
これは日々経験していると思います
いろんなことは思ってはいるんだけど
感じてはいるんだけど
言葉にならない 言葉にならないものは他人に伝えることもできないというよね
言葉がなくても概念を回転することで思考することもできます
これは皆様よく勉強してください
思考するために言葉が必要ではありません
我々は言葉ってあまり使いすぎて
言葉から離れなくなっているだけで
犬猫も考えているんです
よくわかるでしょ あの動物で考えているということは
ちょっと生活を見てみたら
結構考えているんですね
でも言葉がないんです
だから考えるとは この概念を組み合わせたり
回転させたり これとこれとあれとかね
例えば猫がもう畳んである毛布を見る
見たら概念が生まれる
それから自分が暖かいところで
もうふわふわしたところで寝たいという自分の概念がある
その気持ちよく寝たいなという概念と
あ いいものあるんだという概念で
それならそちらに行くぞと
行って寝れば寝ればいいんじゃないと
もう決めてそこまで行くんで
だから思考しなきゃそれできないんです
しかし 我々もそんなことをやっていますよ
考えないで この反射的にやると言ってるでしょ
反射的にやるんじゃなくて
概念でちゃんと判断してやっているんです
で ご飯なんか食べる時はもうかなりこの概念だけでやってるんですね
テレビ見ながら誰かと喋りながらもう食べてるんですね
だから同時に何でもできそうと
同時に何でもできるわけじゃないんです
すべて概念がコントロールしているんです
だからちゃんと概念が概念を組み立てて組み立てて行動しているんです
そこで人と喋ってるんだから
何食べたか 何回食べたかはもうわかってないんですね
でも概念が入ってるんです
人と喋っていても お腹がいっぱいになったらわかっているんだから
あまり食べたくないものは喋っていて
こうやって口に入れたんだけど
え？ってなるでしょ これは食べたくないものやとかね
だから そういう失敗が起きた時は
ちゃんと概念の世界が活動しているんです
だから言葉っていうのは
我々の命の上に乗っている一つの道具なんですよ
それだけです そこで今日は覚えてください
言葉がなくても思考できる
その順番はまず経験ですね
経験というのは これは西洋の単語で
エクスペリエンスですから
このエクスペリエンスというのは
この眼耳鼻舌身に触れることで
経験というものが生まれるんです
体感しまったと感じたと
それを自分で整理するために
他人に伝えるために言語を使います
だから経験したということは
概念が生まれた 私は手を挙げたらもう経験しているんですね
それがそれなりに概念が生まれているんです
しかし それは皆様に言うためには言葉を使う
私は手を挙げまったよということ
です はい 次 言葉から概念へ
単語には必ず概念が入っているので
言語で何かを他人に言うと
それで単語には必ず概念が入っている
前 皆様に見せたプロフェッショナルというあの単語にしても
意味がわからなくても
私もなんかわざと意味を言わないことにしたんですけど
だから意味がわからなくても
あの言葉自体概念を持ってるんですね
だからどんな言葉も概念を持っています
概念を持っていないと言葉ではないんです
言葉を聞くと 我々は何とか反応するんですね
他人に言うと 聞いた人の心に新たな概念が起こるので
今まで知らなかったことが知ったことになります
そこで私がしゃべる しゃべるって言葉がだーっと流れているんですね
流しているんですね この流す言葉が皆様の耳に触れると
触れると 皆様の心の中で概念が生まれる
で 概念が生まれると 皆様方それはどういうのかというと
今まで知らなかったことを知ったということになるんです
今まで知らなかった 知っていたかどうでもいいんだけど
今まで知っていたならばなんか面白くないんですね
今日は土曜日ですよ 面白くないで
そんな言葉は知ってるんだから
例えば来週自分の国のお正月ですけど
それえ？と思うでしょ？それで皆様方は知らなかったことを言ったんです
まあ来週言ったら 4月13日ですけど
スリランカのお正月なんです
もう大騒ぎしてやってるんです
日本でも何かお祭りやると思います
私は招待されませんだから行かないんです
で 結構派手にやります
でも今日は土曜日でしょ？と言ったっていいのだから
ということになるんですね
だから 知らなかったことを心の中に起きちゃうでしょ
それで皆様方はといっても
スリランカ人がやっているお正月は経験できません
皆様方どうするのかというと
自分たちのお正月をイメージして
それを 4月13日に引っ越して
変じゃないの？と思ってるんです 4
月お正月で変でしょうと
あ そう まあそんな連中だからということで
なんとか納得しようとする
だから私が自分の国の文化のお正月っていうことで感じる経験は
皆様に感じられません
言ってあげたのに 違う概念が生まれるんです
いろいろできますよ もう 4月のお正月っていうのは
最近始めたことじゃなくて
これはもうかなり 2000年前からもうやってきたことで
お釈迦様の前からでも
インド文化ではお正月は決まってあったしね
それでインド文化圏に入るどんな国でも
お正月は4月13日に決まってるんです
タイであろうか ミャンマーであろうか
どこでも だから中国人の 2月のお正月よりは
もしかすると民俗的にも幅広いと思います
中国文化は中国人だけだから
インド文化はインド人だけじゃないんです
でも 皆様にとっては日本人だから
変じゃないの？っていう気持ちになる
ですから 言語を使う我々はいつでも知ってるつもりでいるんです
わかるでしょう？私は言葉で何か言ったら皆様に概念が生まれる
でもそれが私が経験した概念ではないでしょう
お正月の例で考えれば
皆様方が経験するお正月は
元旦で行うある特別な文化的なお祭りなんですね
では 私たちにとってのお正月は違う経験なんです
ですから この あなた言うことよくわかるで偉そうなことを言うでしょ
これ成り立たないんです
人がいると 自分が まあ例えばある人が振られて悲しい
悲しくてたまらないんですね
そこで私とそのことを言って
すごい悲しいことを表現して
寂しいと泣いたりする
それで私も同調する 大変ですねとかね
君の気持ちよくわかりますと言うでしょ
嘘でしょ あれは わからないんです
私が自分なりに概念を使って
悲しみってどんなものか
振られてどんなものかと自分の世界で考えている
自分には振られた経験ないんです
これ自慢話じゃなくて
誰とも別に付き合ったこともないんだからね
だから振られる経験もないでしょうに
だから人と付き合った経験もない人が
どうやって振られたことをイメージできますかね
でも その人はね 本当に可哀想で
そう言うと私もやっぱり可哀想だなと思っちゃうんですね
で 私が可哀想や大変ですねとか
同情するその気持ちと
相手が実際経験している気持ちは同じものじゃないんです
だから気をつけてください
我々は言葉でよく喋ってるんだけど
そういう世界です これわからない人々はものすごいトラブル作って
人生は台無しにするんです
あなたに言ったんではないかとかね
そんなこと言っても 言ったでしょうにと言いますけど
言ったのは言ったんだけど
その人の理解はまた別なんです
時々お母さんたちがね
あんた何回言ったらやるのかい？と
子供は正しい答えになれば
これ何回言ったってもやりませんよと
やる気が起こらない限りはと
それが正しい答えですけど
子供にはそこまで能力ないんだから
嫌な反応するだけで だから何回言っても
子供には何かやらなくてはという概念が生まれない限りはやらないんです
そういうことで この社会生活する我々は
ものすごい気をつけなくちゃいけないことなんて
この言葉のやりとり すべて言葉でできそうやと思っているのは
それすごい勘違いなんです
なぜならば 言葉を交わしても
理解することはその人の主観になるからです
だから私は知っているつもりという言葉を使ったんです
私は毎日使っている日常日本語なんですけど
今あるこのすごい深い哲学的な意味で使っているんです
知っているつもりなんです
だから知るってことではないんです
言葉聞いて 我々の心に起こる理解は
知っているつもりの世界なんです
私の講演では 皆様方はよく分かったと言ったっても
それは理解したつもりで知ったつもりになるんです
私が経験して だから私は今日引用しないんだけど
もう中部経典ではものすごい難しい経典がいくつかもう頭の中に入っちゃってね
その場面までできちゃってね
お釈迦様は極々丁寧に一人一人説明するところまで
マドミンダキ経典という中部経典では
10番から 20番の間にある経典で
12番かもしれませんだけど
あるんだけど これかなり大変な難しい経典で
このテーマを調べて研究しているという経典なんですね
だからそこを知っているのに
今日は私は皆様には紹介しないんですね
だから私が概念について知っていることと
私の講演を聞いて皆様方が概念に対し知っていることっていうのは違うんですよ
だから我々は日常生活の中でも
人の話を聞いて まあ理解したつもりで
まあ知っているつもりでいるということにした方が
かなりトラブルが少なくはなります
次 あの これテーマ終わっちゃったんです
生きることと概念 生きるとは信仰や
行為を行為をし続けること
前言った同じことです
反応する 眼耳鼻舌身に入ったデータを概念にして
概念化して 概念化するんじゃなくて
概念になる 瞬間で 眼耳鼻舌身のデータが概念になった瞬間で反応する
反応は身口意の行為というんです
反応はこの 3つしかできません
体で反応するか 言葉として反応するか
考えるという反応するか
どちらかなんです それが生きることです
行為が止まった瞬間で命は終わりますね
行為をするために概念が必要です
だから概念があって反応でしょ
だから生きるために概念が必要です
そこで 生きるために 私は仏教的に言うのは概念が必要ですとかね
例えば宗教になってくると
生きるためには神様の恩恵が必要やってなっちゃうんですね
あのギリシア文字で書いたのはその言葉なんで
プロビデンスと英語で言いますけど
日本訳すると摂理ということになります
でも摂理って場合は 日本では神あまり入らないんですね
自然の摂理 はある それはどちらかで仏教的な意味も入っています
摂理といえば でも西洋の言葉だからね
プロビデンスというのは
それはもうわざわざギリシャ語にしてやったんです
で 生きるためにそういう自然の摂理が必要かと言っていらない
生きるためには概念を作ることが必要です
だから自分がいてもいなくても
自然の摂理があるんです
自分は関係ないんです
だったら自分が生きるということの場合は
概念があって生きているんです
いくつかの概念を組み合わせて
結論 判断という新たな概念を作ります
そこで我々はこの概念
入れて概念を組み合わせるんですね
テレビなんかを見る時はね
テレビで先に画像を見るんですよ
音は後で聞こえるんです
皆様には集中力があれば
そこはチェックできるはずなんですね
人は口を開けて閉めていると音が出ているんですね
すごくズレがあるんですね
私は結構時々もう何も考えないで
どかっと何か見ると あれ
ずれてる おかしいと思ったりする時もあります
でもあれはいつでもあるんです
画像は先 音は後なんです
しかし 私たちにそれ見えな感じないでしょ
これ ナノ秒の速さで起きるものだから
画像を入れて概念を作って
音を入れて概念を作って
そこを合わせて 合わせてからさらに概念を作って
何々人がこういう風に今喋っているんだと
これは生放送だと だからこの本当のところは
脳の中で この因果法則は
この時間の順番で起きていないんです
後で起きた出来事も 脳がしっかり後だと知ってるくせに
いえ 一緒だと決めているんです
テレビに入ったアナウンサーがおはようございますと言ってお辞儀をすると
もう入った顔を見えて
口を開けることも入れてお辞儀をすること見えるんだけど
まあそれと後から音が入ってくるんですね
我々は一遍にして一緒に瞬時に同時に起きたと思っているんです
それはこの脳の中で概念を組み合わせることで成り立たせ
組み合わせる場合はあんまり時間の軸を考えていないんです
だから精密に因果法則はこの調子ではわからないんです
先に起きたことは後に起きたことにするし
後に起きたことは先に起きたことにする
もういろいろ で まあ子供の頃から皆様ね
わかっていることでね
雷の場合はね 雷のは先に見えて
音が後でしょ その時は仕方がありませんね
距離がたくさんありますから
音がのんびり来る時は時間がかかっているんです
それはもういくら脳にしたっても
ごまかすことはできないんですね
しかし 因果法則的に言えば
雷と音が同時に起こるんですね
瞬間で あの電気が何っていうんで放電ですね
放電起きた瞬間ってすごいエネルギーですから
そこで音も現れたんです
しかし 光が先に行って
ちょっと待ったら音も聞こえてくる
しかし 我々の脳にはこんなのを一緒に起こりましょうということは認識できません
それに適した行為を行います
それから判断してから
概念 概念 概念 いくつか概念を組み合わせて
その組み合わせたことは判断になりますね
判断して反応する サンドイッチにするかラーメンにするかと決める時
この働きが起きているんです
この難しく考えないでください
こういうポイントをね
すごい単純にしてください
昼ご飯 サンドイッチにする
ラーメンにすると 自分一人で考えている時はどちらかに決めるでしょ
サンドイッチに決めるか
ラーメンに決める どちらかに決める
そこで脳の中で何が起きるんですかね
サンドイッチに対しての概念が回転させちゃって
それからラーメンに対しての概念を回転させちゃって
それから自分の体の調子やら食欲やら好みやら
いろんな概念を回転させちゃって
無数の概念かき回せて
やっぱりラーメンにしまっと決めた
それでラーメン注文してラーメン食べる
それで行為は起きてるんです
だからどれぐらい概念回転したかというと
これ数えられないんです
数えたければ このラーメンにするかサンドイッチにするかっていう瞬間から
どれぐらいナノ秒かかったかと計算してください
あのナノ秒の数ぐらい概念が回転したんです
だから 1ナノ秒に一つの概念というのは
計算で見ると ナノ秒というのは 1 1 秒の10万分の1でしたっけ？どれぐらいでしたっけ？ま
ネットあればすぐわかりますけど
あんた科学者だから覚えていたと思った
ん？ 10億 うん えっ？うん
はい えーと この科学者の話です
あの 10億 1秒の10億分の 1なんですね
ちょっとわからないね
早すぎ ですから ラーメンに食べるかと
ラーメンにするかサンドイッチにするかといったら
例えば決めるまで 1 分かかったら
どれぐらいですかね  10億かける 60 でしょ
概念の数 それぐらい概念を回転させて
じゃあラーメンにしますと
なるんですね はい それでもうワンポイント終わりました
命には絶対的な 必要なものは概念です
私は瞑想する方々に言うでしょう
命の定義 物体があって
感覚がある それで命やと
感覚が情報を受け取っているんです
情報を受け取った瞬間に概念が生まれるんです
だから概念なし 命も成り立たない
ですから 命と等しい価値をつけているんです
概念と判断がなければ生きられないので
概念があること自体は命を守ることになっているんです
だから概念を大事にするならば
それは命を大事にすることなんです
人は自分の主観的な概念に徹底執着しているんです
だから 人間があの概念に恐ろしく執着しているんです
あれほど早く変化して回転する概念にものすごい執着をしているんです
それも今日初めて学んでください
皆様方 今まで命に対する愛着といえば
よく分かったと思っていたでしょ？分かってないんで
分かったならばもう執着してますからね
でも体験できますね 自分の命は自分に
自分の命に自分が執着している
生きていきたいと思っている
だからそれは分かりますよ
誰でも だから私は私の命にどれぐらい執着しているかとはわかりませんだけど
皆様方は皆様の命に執着していることはわかります
だから殺生できるのはそういうわけなんです
私たちは殺す生命が どれほどその生命が自分の生命に執着しているのかと感じないんですね
だから知って殺しちゃうんですね
もし他の生命が自分の命に対して持っている執着が感じる人にとっては
殺生は不可能になります
自分を殺すことになります
自分を殺される時のあの恐怖感は
生命を殺す時に生まれてくるんです
震えるんです だからできなくなるんです
それで今日 皆様新たに学ぶポイントは
命だけじゃないんだよと
我々は概念にも執着していますよと
そこでわからないのは
概念というのは言葉ではないね
前説明しましたから 言葉より先に生まれるんです
必ず生まれるんです 自我と一体化しています
概念を 考えを否定されたら
自分の存在そのものを否定された気分になるんです
経験あるでしょ？なんか話し合ってる時は
自分が言ったことはもう捨てられたと
あんた言ってることおかしいんだからね
いい加減なことを言うなよと言われたら
すっごい傷つくんです
あれは自我が傷つけられたんですね
だからただのアイデアでしょ
言ったのは ただの概念を言っただけでしょうに
いくつか概念を組み合わせて
それは違いますよ 言われたら別に傷つく必要ないんです
でも傷つくんです 財布が取られても
バカにされることは我慢できない
例えば 皆様の財布が取られちゃったとしましょう
びっくりしますけどもね
それよりバカにされたらすごい傷つくんです
財布が取られて あ 大変だ
損しまった どうしようかというあれよりも
あれはすぐ忘れちゃえ
まあいいやと決めちゃうんです
いとも簡単に忘れちゃうんです
傷つかないんです まあ今度から気をつけますで終わっちゃいます
しかし バカにされたら
それは一生覚えて 恨み通して覚えちゃうんです
で バカにされたっていうことはどういうことかというと
自分の概念を否定されたんです
自分の概念から皆様というのは考えでしょ
自分の考えを否定されたんです
生き方を否定されても同じこと
生き方が概念から生まれるんです
そういうわけで理解してください
我々はお金よりも財産よりも概念に執着しているんだと
では 執着のランクを見ましょうか
自分の命に対する執着は
基本的にそれは本能ですね
ランクの一番トップ 命に対する執着
いわゆる本能です 生きていきたいということは
最強の執着です 生きるために概念を使用して判断しなくてはいけないんです
生きていきたいと それから生きられなくちゃいけないでしょ
次に概念が必要になるんです
概念に対する執着は 2番目になります
執着のランクで 財産 家族などに対する執着は二の次です
家族を大事にするとか
なんだらかんだら偉そうなことを言っても
あれは執着ランクのね
二の次なんです 私は意図的に 3番目と書かなかったんです
二の次だと 曖昧なんです
それも家族を捨てる時もありますからね
家族を不幸に陥れることもありますからね
だから 3番目の執着はとは言えません
正しい単語は二の次です
日本語って便利ですね
いろんなこと言えます
言えますから 政治 社会
生き方などに対する考え
意見 哲学などに対する執着は弱いので変更できます
変更できるでしょ 例えば
自分が政治理論を持っていて
まるまる党ですよと決めていたっても
後で考え変わっちゃって
いえ あの党じゃなくてこの党やと
それから我々 我々考えているものいっぱいあるでしょ
世間に対して 政治 世界に対して
経済状況に対して 日本の社会に対して
国際状況に対して こんな考えっていうのはもうすぐすぐ変わります
執着はあるんだから そういうことを考えているんです
日本の経済は本当に大丈夫なのかと心配する場合は
やっぱり執着があるんですよ
でも ああいう思考っていうのは
ドロドロドロドロ変わっちゃいます
なぜならば 執着は弱いんです
執着は強ければ それはなかなか
政治理論を変えても 家族に対する愛着を捨てなさいと言ったら
それできないでしょう
はい これがランクです
はい 次 仏教の話に入ります
正行無常 概念そうも無常です
はい 今まで概念 概念という言葉を使ったんだけど
五蘊の中で想蘊というのがあるんですね
それが概念です 色蘊 受蘊
想蘊ですね ループでな三輪
はい それから行 それから識
認識の識 グループでな
三者三界ある これで三者というのは概念です
正行無常であるであるならば
そうも無常でしょ 当たり前のことなんです
色声香味触法という情報が常に触れるので
結果として起こる そう
概念も常に変化して変わるんです
何か見ているとは光がぶつけて逃げているんですよ
スーッと だからその速度で感覚が変わっているんです
そこで新たな新たな新たな概念想が生まれて生まれて生まれているんです
これも 1秒 7 秒の速さで概念が変化しているんです
従って 判断も行為も常に変えなくてはならないんです
概念が変わると変わる
変わるたびに 我々はそれに対する反応も行為も変えて変えていかなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで皆様に歩く瞑想できれば
本当に徹底的に執着 執着じゃなくて集中してこれは経験できます
観念的な話ですけど 例えば
ある人がすべての雑念がなくなっちゃって
歩く瞑想をする これで左足といった時の概念
自分が変わっている 上げると言っちゃうと自分が変わっていく
行為も変わっていく 上げたところで運ばなくちゃいけない
新たな判断が現れてきて
これを運ぶために必要な概念が生まれてきて
それで運ぶ 運んだところで判断して
じゃあ下ろすと それで恐ろしいスピードで概念が変わっていって
想が変わっていて そのために自分というもの
全体的にも変わっていくんだと
って見えるんですね そこまで見たらもうすぐすぐすぐ解脱を達しますけどね
しかし 強烈な執着が障害になります
この理解に邪魔するのは執着なんです
私がここからあそこまで歩いたぞと
嘘ばっかりで 私がいるわけないんです
瞬間瞬間 自分が変わったんです
執着のせいで すべてまとめて私という箱に入れちゃうんです
存在しない箱に だから執着が我々にはものすごい邪魔で
概念にしがみついているので
変わる状況に合わせて自分を変えることができません
そこで我々はあまりにも概念にしがみついているんだから
常に状況が変わっていくんです
しかし 私にとってはその変動と一緒に変化することはできないんです
止まっちゃうんです 新幹線に乗って不可能ですけど
窓から手を出して何か捕まってるような感じなんです
ひどい目に遭うんです
目の安全期待するならば
中に入って変化することと一緒にやらなくちゃいかんのです
一緒に変化しなくちゃいけないんです
一緒に変化するのに 自我の錯覚でやっぱり止まろう
止まろう 止まろうとありえないことをやって
無理なことをやろうとして
自然法則に逆らうことをやろうとして
ただ単に苦労するだけ
はい そういうことで 我々は生きる上でありとあらゆるトラブルを作っちゃうんです
どんなトラブルでも 変わったものに自分を変えることはできなかっただけなんです
精密に考えれば 状況が変わって当然変わっている
例えば 自分が外へ出て何かやって家に戻る
家に戻ると頭の中で新たな概念を作ってますね
家はこんな感じで こんな感じであってほしいとかね
そこでドアを開けてみたら
全く違う環境 あれはみんなギャーギャーと遊んでいるだろうとかね
自分がいると お母ちゃん帰ったというふうにみんな喜ぶだろうとイメージ作った
自分のことにお母ちゃんおかえりとかね
言うだろうとか思っていた
そこで自分変わっちゃったんです
なんか期待に固まった自分
自分が玄関開けたら誰もいない
子供の声もしない それに自分を変化することはできない
突然ショックで大変だ
どんなことですか？とか泣き叫んだり
ものすごい対応できなくてトラブっちゃうんです
だから そんな単純な例でなくても
上司に叱られたと それで落ち込んじゃったということも同じことなんですね
自分の前の状態は変えたくはなかったんです
これ不可能です 気持ちよく偉そうな態度
で会社にいたかったんです
それで新たな無常だから
上司の言葉っていうものは起きちゃったんですね
それに対応できなくなっちゃって
ガクンと落ち込んじゃう
する 自分を瞬間に変えることができたならば
その場面に自分を変えちゃうんです
執着なければできます
執着さえなければ なんで怒っているのか
どういうことを言っているのかとかね
そういうことですか？と
ああ そうですねという
納得いくんです なんのことなく
ああ この失敗 私がやってないのに
私がやった失敗ではないんだけど
上司がまあ私だと思ってるんだから
その勘違いによって今ギャーギャー言ってるんだと
なるほどと納得いくんです
納得というと 実は上司
これ私の管轄ではないんだけどと言えるし
落ち込まないで その場合は
あるいは自分がやったこと
ああ なるほど 失敗したんだから
まあ叱られている で納得いく
そういうわけで この精神的な苦しみ
悩み トラブル 落ち込み
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみなどなどが起こるはずがないものなんです
千五百煩悩も起こるはずがないんです
この執着 これ作っちゃうんです
執着とは変えたくはないという意味なんです
変えたくはないって何なのか
すべて無常なのに それで不幸の扉を開くんです
概念に執着して変えることができなくなったら
無常の流れに適応できませんね
だから適者生存だからね
世の中は 頑固になって自分の判断で生きようとする
頑固になったら この判断というものは変えないんですね
判断は無常ですけど 同じ判断するんですね
だから自分が判断変えなかったと勘違いする
本当はそれも無常なんです
ある人に嫌な顔を見せると判断する
その人は明日来ても嫌な顔をするんだけど
同じ判断ではなくて 新たな判断なんですよ
自分が見せる嫌な顔も毎日同じじゃないんです
でも自分が錯覚で同じ判断でいると思ってるんですね
辛苦の行為は過ちになる
行為は間違っちゃいます
結果は失敗と不幸です
辛苦意の行為は生きることです
辛苦意の行為が誤りだったら
生きること自体が不幸です
失敗になるんです 生きることはさらに苦しくなる
なんでさらに苦しくなると書いたんですかというと
生きることは大変なんですよ
いくら判断正しくても
いくら無常をわかっていても大変なんで
生きることは で これは誰にでもある普遍的な大変さもあるのに
その上不幸になるんです
間違った判断はさらに間違って間違ってではなくて
間違った判断に誘導するんです
一つの判断間違ったら
それから大変なことになりますよ
安心と安らぎを目指して
次 判断行動は間違えますので
間違いのでね 何か変わらないガイドライン
常に参考できる固定 これ固定でいいんですかね
固定固定したです  うん
いわゆる変わらないという意味のこれでいいんですか？うん
そこでこの間違いだらけの人間が判断間違った
また判断間違った また判断間違った
また対応間違ったと悩んでるでしょ
私は何回失敗したら終わるのかい？とか心配するでしょ
よくあることは 離婚して人は再婚してまた離婚するんだからね
だから皆様も知ってるでしょ
何か間違ったら同じことをまたやっちゃう
またやっちゃう またやっちゃう
そういう人生でしょ みんな
うん それ嫌でしょ？同じ失敗
何でも何でも繰り返し繰り返しやるの
嫌でも仕方がないでしょうに
その気持ちは誰にでもありますよ
あるんだけど また失敗する
そこで私たちは心の安心
安らぎを目指して ある対策をとるんです
失敗繰り返しの人生でしょ
誰にでも同じことです
悟ってない限りは 人生は失敗の繰り返しです
これ嫌だから対策を練るんです
じゃあ失敗しないように何か参考になるもの
何かないのかと 何か参考する何か見てOKという
そういう何か欲しがるんです
私に皆様質問するときでもそれ聞いてるんですね
で 会社でこういうことになったんだけど
どうすればいいんですか？と
だからいつでもポケットに入れて
携帯でそれを参考にして反応しようではないか
それに参考そういう変わらない何か欲しがっちゃうんですね
固定した何かガイドラインのね
何か変わらないガイドライン
常に参考できる固定した概念があった方が良いのでしょうという風に思っちゃうんです
社会に 周りにどのような変化が起きても
安心して自分の固定概念に合わせて参考してみれば
解決判断は簡単ではないでしょうかと
なんかそう思わない？いくら変化したっても大丈夫
こうしますと 携帯できる何かガイドラインあった方がいいと思ってますね
これで人は固定概念 理論
見解 主義 信仰などを作るんです
こういうわけで これが間違っています
はっきり言えば怠けなんです
何かガイドライン携帯して
いつでもそれを参考しようかなと
何考えてるんだ？例えば会社で仲間でちょっと喧嘩になった
これ持ってはい こうしなさいと反応して
それから家で自分の子供３人がギャーギャー喧嘩して
またあれをポケットから取って
あんた方はこうしなさいと同じことで反応しようとする
これでおかしくない？あれ
怠けじゃない？結局は無常を否定しようとしているんです
会社の仲間が喧嘩する条件と
三人兄弟が喧嘩することっていうのはまるっきり違うんです
会社の喧嘩はものの見事にやめさせた人に
3人兄弟の喧嘩をやめさせることはできないんです
同じ手段は適用できません
そこで 奥さんが隣の家の奥さんと喧嘩するときは
子供 3人を喧嘩を収めた方法を使ったらいい
アウト それは別世界です
だから喧嘩になったら喧嘩やめる方法を教えてちょうだいと私に聞いてもよく聞くんだから
私もまあ知ってるんだから
仕方がなく答えていますよ
でも時々言うんで この答えはこのケースだけやと
他のものには適用できませんと
これが正しい道なのに
我々はいつでも参考にできる
携帯できる何かガイドラインが欲しくて探したところで哲学を作る
カントやらデカルトやら
あれやこれやとかいるんだからね
もう無知な連中が で それからいろんな見解を作る
見解っていろいろアイデアですね
それから主義を作る 信仰を作る
だからどんなトラブルがあっても
お参りできる神社が隣にいればありがたいでしょ
夫婦喧嘩になった途端
神社に行って神様お願いしますと
子供はもうちょっと勉強できなくなってしたくなくなったらトラブルでしょ
神様ちょっとお願いします
うちの子は勉強できますようにと
それで会社で自分は降格させたら
神様お願いします 昇格できますようにとかね
そうやって信仰という一つ概念を作って
すべてそちらで解決しようというふうに
信仰はそういうものなんです
だから宗教を作った人々はみんな何があっても私に聞けという態度で言ってるんです
でも何も解決してないんですよ
宗教は 人間の問題はなにひとつも
でも固定した概念でいくんですね
主義あるでしょ 世界の問題を解決するために
この主義陣だよとかね
共産主義やら資本主義やら
もうもうアメリカだったらフリーという
なんだかわけもわからない
何の自由もない国ですけど
まあ自由という主義やらね
いろんなものを作っちゃうんですね
共産主義といったっても
これまた変わっちゃいますからね
まあ中国も今はもう共産主義ですけど
あれは何の共産主義かよくわかりませんね
あのタイム雑誌にあったのは
この何でしたっけ あの習近平さん
大統領の主席の あの習近平さんがね
あのマオツェトンの形をなろうとしているんだと
あまりにも独裁的で もうマオツェトングではちょっとカルチャー
カルチャー なんどらかってね
レボリューション文化革命ですごいトラブっちゃったんだから
まあそこはもう考えて
そうではなく もう絶対的修復というふうに
修復じゃなくて 絶対的に自分の人がいなさいと
ね そういう感じでなんとか今はやっていて
他の共産主義の人々にはちょっともうこれ邪魔だなとか嫌だなという気持ちもあるという記事でしたけどもね
まあどうでもいいんですけど
とにかく主義を作っちゃうんですね
はい そういうことで あべこべ世界が現れるんです
無常の現象を無視して不幸の扉を開け
開けました これが良くないとわかって頼りになる固定した変わらない見解
概念などを作って 人生をそれに合わせる
不幸の扉を開いた 開けたことは一応あまり気づいていないんだけど
不幸は感じてますね 失敗はよくわかっているんですね
わかっているんだから
これを何とかしなくちゃいけないと思っちゃって
頼りになるものを作る
頼りになるのは固定した概念なんですね
変わらない 何かを欲しがるんです
私は聞いた そんな変わらないもの世の中にあるのかと
そこで魂は変わらないでしょう
えーと 天国は永遠で変わらないでしょう
ないこっちゃ 西洋の宗教が言ってる地獄も永遠に苦しむでしょう
この連中 よく永遠という言葉を使うんだから
のこのこと 2足す2は4だ程度の知識
理解能力があれば 永遠という単語成り立たないと
わかるのに やっぱり変わらない何か欲しがるんですね
そこで変わらない何もないのに
いわゆる幻覚 獣 物の怪を作って
それに人生を捨てるんです
それってあべこべ態度なんです
無常に逆らおう逆らおう
無常無視しよう 無常見ないことにしようと
だから永遠が欲しがるんです
永遠が欲しがったのはものは無常だからでしょうに
ものは無常だったら なんで永遠を欲しがるかというと
無常に対応できなかったからでしょうに
おっかないからでしょうに
無常は だったらそこら辺でどうすればいいかと理解するべきなのに
永遠のものはあるかないかもわからないのに
物の怪を作っちゃうんです
それから人間の生き方
すべてあべこべなんです
我々は何やってもいたってやってはいけないことです
何やってみたっても よくよく見ると
それはやってやらなかった方がよかったことばっかりです
これでいいんですかね
人生は 朝から晩までやることはほとんどやらなかった方がいいものばっかりなんですね
例えば殺人を犯して それが失敗の行為だとわかったところで
解決はさらに殺し続けることだと判断したようなものです
我々やっているのは このたとえ話のようなものなんです
殺人をやっちゃった あ
これは判断間違ったと
あ ダメだ これはと じゃあどうすれば？じゃあ殺し続ければ
これって答えですかね
だから無常に適応できなかったところで
不幸の扉を開いて 同じことをやり続けるんです
とことん無常に反対しましょうよと
無常反対だと 永遠万歳だと
そんなのはあるのか？と聞きたくなるんですね
はい 不幸の流れが自己破壊の流れに変わるんです
そこで新たな流れが現れるんです
もう今 我々は無常と一緒に不幸で流れていくんですね
この不幸の流れがさらに破壊の流れになるんです
だから順番ミス 無常の流れ
これは仕方がありません
自然の摂理です この無常の流れに適応できなかったところで
不幸が流れ始めるんです
それは嫌だと思ったところで
あべこべなことをやったところで
破壊の流れが現れるんです
えーと まあそろそろ休憩にした方がいいと思いますけど
あとちょこっと言ってからね
無明という言葉を勉強しましょう
真夏の太陽のように明らかな無常を発見できない
無常って発見するのは難しくない
全て無常だから 無常をならざるものはないんだから発見できませんって
何言ってるんですかね
無常をならざるものはないんです
これ発見できない 無視する
否定することが正しいと思う
無常を無視すること 否定することが正しい道
生きる道やと思ってるんです
みんな 従って真理に逆らう
それで不幸の扉が開けるんですね
真理に逆らう時点で もう不幸の扉
だからお釈迦様が生きることは苦の流れですよと
なぜならば 生きることとは
やっぱり無常に逆らうことになるんです
これが無知無明 パーリ語でアウィッジャというんです
決して隠れない 逃げない
無常をなぜ発見できない
発見しないでしょうか
何が障害になっているのでしょうか？無常は逃げない
隠れない 堂々と 一切は無常
無常をならざるものはない
でも私には発見できない
何が私に障害があるんですね
例えば こんな広大な世界は見えないと人が言うならば
その人にあるでしょう
世界に問題あるわけじゃないでしょう
そういうことで 例えば
こんなにうるさいこの世界は全く何の音もありませんと
あなたがいくらうるさいと言ったっても
私には音は全く聞こえないと言ったら
問題は誰にあるんですかね
その人にあるんですね
そういうことで 一切は無常なのにわかりませんと言ったら
障害が自分にあるんです
わかりませんという人に
では この障害は何ですか？放逸
怠けから欲しすぎと 生きること自体は大変疲れる作業です
頑張り続けても終わり
終了などはありません
怠けたいという気持ちは自然に生じる
生かされていると勘違いしていても
実は自分で生きているんです
この生かされているって
あれ怠けなんですね でも
生かされていると偉そうなこと言ったっても
あなたが自分で生きているんです
では 決まった変更しない概念
主義 信仰などの何かがあった方が手抜きできます
大変だから生きることは
それで人は信仰を作るんです
固定概念を作るんです
主義を作るんです 主義を作ったら手抜きできます
例えば 自分の子供が重病で治らないとわかる
もうものすごい大変な問題でしょう
もう受け取れたくないんで
この事実は 自分の子供だから
何としてでも治療して治したいんです
でも医者がこれ治りませんと言っちゃうんです
そこでものすごい苦しみを感じるんです
そこで助けになるのは信仰です
それは慈悲深い 無量の慈悲を持っている神様がとか考えたことだから
あんた心配しなくていいやと
ああ そうです 神様 じゃあお願いしますと
でも子供は死にますけどね
だから変わらない何か
で うちの子は神様は早くも天国に呼ばれましたと
呼び出しましたと そういうふうに自分をなんとかごまかすんです
それに私はお前のことは神様はすごい嫌いみたいやと言うんです
で あれって怠けですね
結局は 生命は放逸で欲しすぎなんです
これでダメなんですよ
あれ 放逸 怠けたいんですね
サボりたい サボりたいんですよ
サボりたい気持ちない？あるんですよ
手抜きしたい気持ちがない？あるんです
なんか楽にできる方法ないとかね
何か裏技でもないのかと聞いているでしょ
いつでも それから保守主義でしょ
面白いです この革命を謳っている人々も頑固な保守主義なんです
気持ち悪いほど保守主義なんです
例えば保守主義という人々はいくらか柔軟で変えられますよ
私は何かプログレッシブな人間で
推進 進歩派であれやこれやとものすごい頑固なんです
気持ち悪いんです 例えば
共産主義という政治システム自体がレボリューションで革命的でしょ
では 北朝鮮で何か革命的なこと起こる？何も起こらないでしょう
もう超気持ち悪い保守主義でしょ
政治家さえ変えられません
ある家族だけになっているんです
だから昔の時代にあった王政の時代と同じでしょうに
はい それで我々はいつでもこれでいいという
これはする技能権というんですか？モロハの権
権で遊んでいるんです
不幸に陥っている時 失敗した時
解決策を見つけて楽になった時
これでいい これでよかったと思われます
これは自然です  これでいいということは
一概に悪くはないんです
本当に大変な状態になっていて
もうどうせどうのどうないもうどうたいって
それで何か解決策を見つかる
あ これでよかったと思うでしょ
ああ よかったと それはいいんです
しかし 人生全体に対して適用すると精神の癌になってしまいます
だからこれでいいと腰をつけて座ることは不可能なんです
ケースバイケースでいいんです
例えば もうトレッキングじゃなくて
どこかで山歩きをする
歩いて歩いて歩いて歩いて
もうクタクタ疲れて それでそこら辺腰をかけるところがあって
水を飲むところがある
そこで腰をかけて ああ
よかった じゃあ水一杯でも飲もうか
ちょっとそれでいいんですよ
しかし 山の上まで歩けないでしょ
これでいいやと そこで座ったら
それが不幸になるでしょ
はい それは精神の癌になりますよ
これでいいということは
成長 進歩 より良い幸福へ進むことができなくなります
だから これでいいということが
諸刃の剣になっちゃうんです
気をつけましょう 生きることは退化の流れに変わってしまいます
もし人がこれでいいと落ち着いたことを考えたら
もう退化します はい こういうところでちょっと 10分ぐらい休憩いたします
これからの解決策に行きます
はい では始めます はい
次はの この我々がやっている
この微妙なこの不幸の流れ
この微妙といっても これ根本的な基本的なところですからね
取り除く方法 原因はたった一つです
執着です で 無常だから執着できないでしょうに
でも変わるのは困るんですね
欲しすぎだから 困るとは執着なんですね
だから執着グラスピンというその一言葉なんです
執着してはいけないということで
意見に見解に執着する
自己と一体化してしまう
自分の主義 自分の信仰
自分の考え 自分だと思っているんです
だから自分は何やといったら
結局自分の考えてるんです
自分とはこの肉体でしょ
誰も言いませんね 絶対変えないで守ろうとする
これ 自分というものを絶対守ろう守ろうとするんで
これは何ですか？と 執着でしょうに
見解が溜まって溜まってスグレスグルになる
そうなってくると 守ろうとすることであらゆる見解が来て
もう執着するでしょ 見解自体が溜まるんですね
見解で言ったら例えば概念
溜まって溜まって溜まって溜まって
例えば勉強しすぎるなるとどうにもならなくなっちゃうでしょうに
あまりにも妄想すると
もう人生そのものを破壊するでしょう
だけど 溜まって溜まってもう
ダムがもう壊れるんですよ
もう そういうわけで これでいいというリミットを作らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
みんな我々は人生ですぐあ
これでいいと決めて そこから退化するんです
例えば勉強する時でも
あ まあこの年まで勉強して
これ何年間？ 5年 6年でそれでやめますとかね
いつでも何やっても我々はリミットを作るんですね
ここまでと そこはもうそうするしかなくなっちゃうんですね
これで溜めるのは苦しい
ものは溜めていくことは苦しいんです
ものだけではなく 知識
概念なども溜めるのは苦しいんですよ
溜めて溜めていくと 特に苦しいのは
我々はこの この無数の概念だったら
溜めても気がつかないんですね
ほとんど忘れているんです
ではなくて いくつかの概念
妄想 思考 こればっかり回転させて回転させて溜めるんですね
これがもう耐えられない苦しみになっちゃうんです
無限に溜めることは不可能です
いくら溜めても足りるということにはなりません
で 無限に溜めることもできませんし
いくらか溜めたから まあこれで足りるということもないんです
溜めたものを 攻撃的に守らなくてはいけない
何かの概念に執着したら
この主義なんかは一つ二つですよ
皆様は 資本主義と共産主義
両方持つことはできないでしょうに
独裁的政治がよろしいと
民主的な政治よろしいやと両方思うことはできません
だからもう何か一つ主義を持って
これは頑固と守る そのためには攻撃体制にならなくちゃいけないんです
すべては無常なのに 守る体制は自然
宇宙の法則に一人で逆らうことになります
これで我々は概念をに執着して
それを守ろうとする それは自然法則に逆らうことなんです
たとえ金に執着して金を守ろうしたっても
自然法則に逆らうことなんです
家族に執着して家族を守ろうしたっても
これはあり得ないことで
誰も家族を守ったことになってないんです
ただ守っているという思っているだけなんです
家族の一人一人は自分で生きているんだから
別に守ってくれなくてもいいんだけど
しかし 守らなくちゃという気持ちが生まれたら
保守主義になったら 次
攻撃ということは現れてくるんですね
攻撃しなくちゃいけないんですね
ある程度でこれでいい
止まることも間違った答えです
だから この程度でいいと思って
執着にリミットを作ることも法則違反だ
それも正しくはないんです
だから仏教の答えは無執着
放すこと ブッダがとるに
それは幸福の道 だから我々はこの概念に執着することで
無常に反対することで道が誤ったんです
それでなかった不幸の扉を開いたんです
そこで人間が決めたことは
ある程度で執着程度知りましょうと
執着程度ってないんです
金を儲かることは いくら儲かってもキリがない
じゃあそれはダメだから
ある程度で決めましょうと
でもそれも執着だから
決めた程度の金たまったら
それ守らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
知識はこの程度の知識あればいいやと
例えば大学卒業するまで勉強するぞと
大学は学部卒業したら
あ これで十分やと 十分ですかね
それで知識は それで十分かと思っても
その知識を守らなくちゃいけないし
消えていくんだからね
だからまあある程度も良くないんですよ
ある程度の執着も だからお釈迦様が無執着が正しい
手放すことが正しいと思っているんです
次 見解の問題 見解はディッキというんですね
仏教用語で これが正しいと結論を無理につけています
見解っていうのは このこれが正しいと結論付けることなんです
例えばリンゴは美味しい
結論でしょ これ見解です
正しくないんです それはリンゴは美味しくないって意味ですかね
リンゴは美味しくないってことは結論でしょ
見解です 正しくないんです
だからリンゴは美味しいと間違っている
リンゴは美味しくない
間違っている ではリンゴは何なのかというと
かなり大変ですよ 答えるの
無常だから その都度その都度美味しく感じてたり
甘く感じたり 各リンゴはそれぞれ違うんだから
取ったばっかしのリンゴがあるし
もう完熟したリンゴもあるし
そこそろそろそこそこ完熟した熟したリンゴもあるし
それはまあ種類によっても変わるし
リンゴの種類もたくさんありますからね
だからうかつに単純でリンゴは美味しいと決めたら
これ怠けなんです だから正しいのは
リンゴは美味しいという意見にも執着しない
リンゴは美味しくないという意見にも執着しない
その都度その都度で結果が出るだけだと
だから無執着にいる そうすると楽なんです
見解に必ず反対の意見も生じます
しかし 我々はちょっとハンディ持っていて
結論したいんですよ 概念があったら判断したいんです
判断したら動けるんです
ラーメンにするかサンドイッチにするかっていう答え
疑問出したらどうします？何時間も悩む？何日も悩む
パッパッと判断したいでしょ
これがかなりハンディなんです
そこで我々は次から次へと判断していくんです
もう判断結論ばっかしの人生なんです
日本人がなんか民族的にイエスノーはっきりしませんよと言ってるわりに
ものすごい見解 意見にしがみついて執着しているんです
自分の生き方 絶対変えたくないんですね
だから結論に凍り固まってるんですよ
あれは嘘ですよ 日本人があのイエスノーはっきりしませんっていうのは
ものすごいもう 見解に固執しているんです
イエスノーとしたところで責任持たなくちゃあかんです
攻撃を受けなくちゃいけないんで
これ弱いんですね これ避けるために別な結論逃げるんです
それだけの話です それで結論したら
これは見解です 見解が生まれたら問題があります
反対の意見も成り立ちます
アンティテーシスが現れるんです
避けられません すべての見解に反対の見解も現れて
高いと言ったら低いということは出てきます
安いと言った途端 同じで値段的に高いということは出てきます
美しいと言ったら醜いという言葉が現れます
仕方がありません 見解というものは必ず反論を作るんです
どちらが正しいと言えないので
論と異論があるとどちらが正しいと言えないんです
自分の見解を何としてでも守らなくてはいけなくなります
そういうわけで 自分が決めた見解を守らなくちゃいけない
例えば 私はリンゴは美味しいと見解を持ったら
相手がいや リンゴは美味しくないと言ったら
あ そう じゃあリンゴは美味しくないと
私はおかしいでしょうに
私はリンゴは美味しいという立場を弁解しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
仕方がなく見解にはめるはめられるんです
だから見解を持つこと自体が喧嘩を生んだことなんです
トラブルを作ったことなんです
相手の見解に寝返りすることではプライドが傷つきますね
これできないんです 見解は戦い
勝敗を招くんです だからこの世の中でなんで戦いあるんですかと
見解があるからなんです
見解っていうのは無常に結論付けちゃったんです
これ間違いです 見解に執着しなくてはならないのです
だから見解を作ったら
あんた自分の意見を守れ
自分の意見に執着しなさいということになるんです
例えばある人が日本和食が世界一美味しいという見解を作る
あの見解イコール邪見なんです
だから邪見という言葉を言っちゃうと正見でも来ますから
これも見解ではないかというトラブルを作るんだから
言語学的にね 私は邪見という言葉を使っていないんです
見解ディッティ お釈迦様はすごいというそういうわけなんです
ものの見事にこの用語を私たちに教えられているんです
だから私はミッチャーディッティという言葉を使わないで
ディッティという言葉で今日の説法をやっているんです
この説法をする時も お釈迦様はミッチャーディッティという邪見という言葉を使わないんです
ディッティという言葉でお釈迦様さえ説法をなさったんです
だから この智慧の完成には本当にもうもうびっくり動転するんです
で 何か見解を作ったら
それを守る羽目になります
それがに それに執着する羽目になります
見解あったんだけど すぐ寝返りするんだったら意味がないでしょ
例えば和食の問題だけど
和食こそ世界一美味しい食べ物やと
もう見解を作る その人は例えば外国旅行して
そこでレストランで日本食もあって
他の国の文化的に作った腕のいいコックさんたちが作った料理も並んでいる
外国だからあんまり和食作った人の腕がいいとはちょっと思いづらいんですよ
でもこの見解を持っちゃうと
この人どうなる？下手なコックさんが作った和食を食べる羽目になるんです
だって世界一美味しいものあるんだからね
もしかすると外国の文化で
そのコックさんが作った料理がかなり腕があるんです
その料理に対して だから批判的に見れば
そちらの料理の方が美味しいはずなんです
でも見解を持っちゃうと
誰かあんた和食世界一美味しいやと言いならば
なんで今和食あるのにフランス料理食べてるんですか？と馬鹿にされます
だから自分の見解を守るために
もう豪華なフランス料理もあるのに
質素な和食を食べる羽目になっちゃうんです
そういうことで あまりいい例えじゃないね
これ 見解を持つことでバカを見ることは結構ありますよ
結局は 主義持っちゃうとこうね
例えばもう菜食主義やと思ったらね
いくら美味しい食べ物あったっても
食べられなくなったりするしね
肉しか私は食べませんよと決めたら
美味しい他の料理もいっぱいあるのに
野菜料理もあるのに ちょっと食べられなくなっちゃうんですね
だから何か見解を持ったら
そこでそれを守る それで自分の生き方を制限されちゃうんですね
それで執着っていうのは
当たり前 見解と執着はまあ一緒です
セットです 心の中に起こる様々な概念を組み合わせて固定した判断に達することは見解です
見解の成り行き 心にいろんな概念が流れるんですね
無数に ナノ秒のスピードで概念が入って消えて入って消えて入って消えて
その流れる概念をいくらか組み立てて固定した判断を作るんですね
それに見解というんです
一人の人間に無数の見解が起こります
それらの見解に対して反論もあります
他の人間にも同じく無数の見解があるんです
見解に執着しなくてはいけないし
持論を守らなくてはいけませんね
ひどいことを自分で招くんだから
正しいと立証不可能な持論のせいで
人の人生は潰れます 見解は正しいと決して成立することはできません
リンゴは美味しいと成立することできません
これはその時その時なんです
見解は作れません 例えば
納豆は体にいい食べ物やと健康にいいものやと見解を作ったら
その人は納豆ばっかり食べなくちゃいかんでしょ
病気になって死にますからね
それって見解だから間違いなんです
納豆は美味しい 健康にいい食べ物と言ったら
いえ 違いますよという人々もいくらでも現れます
納豆にはこれがない これがない
これがないと それで納豆にはこういう悪い物質も入ってますよとかね
いくらでも言えます したがって納豆が悪いと
見解を作ったら反論もある
自分を作った見解を自分で守る羽目になる
それで戦う羽目になる
問題は一人の人に見解は無数にある
無数にあります 宗教的になってくると
見解は決まっている 存在になってくると
魂は永遠か不滅 永遠ではないかとか
見解っていうのはだいたい 64 に分けてますから
それたくさんないんです
邪見という見解はそんなにたくさんないんです
見解といったら無数です
見解は邪見という単語に入れ替えると数えられます
例えば魂が永遠にあるという邪見
唯物主義だよという邪見 2つですね
見解はかなりあるんです
見解の問題は正しいと立証することは不可能です
正しいならば反論が成り立ちません
例えば 地球が丸いということも見解のように見えるでしょう
地球が丸いに決まっている
決まっている だったら見解でしょ
あれ 見解じゃないんです
なぜならば 形として考えれば
これは丸いんですね 精密に見れば丸くないかもしれませんだけど
本当は精密数学的に見ると丸くないんです
完璧なスフィアじゃないんです
北と南の方がちょっとつぶられてますからね
それから地球の表もね
ギザギザでしょ だから精密な球ではないんだけど
まあ大ざっぱで言えばまあ球体ですね
それが見解じゃない なぜならば立証できるんです
なぜならば 異論は成り立たないんですね
反論がないんです 太陽のエネルギーで生きているんだよと言ったら
反論が成り立たない そういう反論ないものは立証されているんです
反論があったら立証されてないんです
訂正アンチテーゼ両方あるんだったら
どちらでもいい加減で
そういうわけで 仏教で言うのは見解ではなく智慧ですと
地球が丸いということは
そんな大した智慧ではないんだけど
一応立証されているんですね
間違いなくと 地球が太陽を回っているんだということは
まあ立証済みです だからそれは智慧程度ではないんだけど
そこで執着する必要がない意見が現れるんです
見解で退化することを避けるために智慧を育てます
見解を持っちゃうと退化
退化に行く その代わりに智慧を育てます
それには瞬間瞬間変わ変化生滅
なんか漢字がおかしいな
生滅していく現象を先入観を避けてありのままに観察するという実践を行います
だから無常を発見する
実践しなくちゃあかんですね
無常を発見すると見解が潰れていくんです
無常を発見することが智慧なんですね
次から次へと見解が成り立たないと発見するので
各見解を捨てることになるんです
見解にとらわれず捨てられることが智慧です
智慧っていうのはこの捨てられる
だからこれかなり勇気が必要になります
新たな概念を溜めることではありません
智慧っていうのは 今まで勉強したものにプラスアルファで何か勉強することじゃないんです
捨てて捨てて捨てていく
破って破って破っていく
何もたまらないんです
だからすごく自由になるんです
破れば破るほど自由になるんです
だから知識は重い 智慧は重さがない
無重力です それで智慧の順番っていうのは
例えば私がギャーギャーギャーと神に対して悪口言ってるでしょ
それを私は感情的に言ってるんじゃなくて
理想と理性で論理的に
まあもう自分も神は存在しないとありえないと発見もしているし
だからそこは言ってますけど
そこで私の話を聞いてきて
皆様はもしかするとやっぱり一神
神様を信じることはおかしいなとわかると
今まで信仰あった邪見を捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそうやって一つ破って捨てて
新しいものになるかも
それをまた調べて破って
新しいものになる それも破ってというふうに進んでいくんです
そこで見解破れたことが智慧というんです
見解は煩悩も持ってるんだから
そこで見解もある 喧嘩も現れますからね
そこで柵になっているんです
智慧とは自由の世界ですからね
執着するとは束縛することで
能力は制限されます 執着する人には能力はもう制限します
智慧とは無執着なので
自由が成り立ちます 制限はないんです
知る世界 知られる世界に制限は成り立ちませんが
例えば智慧があったら
知る世界にも知られる世界にも制限ない
皆様に見解やったら 知る世界はリミットされます
見解やったら 見解に見られる世界だけです
それも湾曲された世界
見解がなかったら いくらでも知ることは可能です
俗世間的にも知られる世界もあります
最終的に智慧は無常を発見することになるんです
だから 宇宙はどう現れたのか
宇宙はどんな風なものか
魂はまあ命はどんな風のものか
輪廻転生するのかしないのか
業はどんな働き 何でも知れますよ
知恵さえあれば 制限ないんです
智慧が現れたら 見解を作らない心が現れたら
知りたいものは何でも知り得る
でも面倒くさい そんなのは
だから最終的な智慧っていうのは無常を発見することです
知りたいという足かせも消える
それであれも知りたい
これも知りたいという欲もなくなっちゃうんです
例えば 皆様方は本当に輪廻転生はありますか？と私に聞くでしょう
どうやって無我なのに輪廻するのかい？とかね
瞑想して悟ったら その質問しないんです
そんなのはどうでもいいってことになってるんです
面倒くさいやと 知りたいという欲もなくなっているんです
知りたいということは
要するに足かせなんです
で 究極の幸福 見解がある限り
幸福とは何かと理解することさえ不可能です
見解ある人間は幸福わかりません
理解することさえ不可能です
見解と喧嘩なんです あるのは見解と争いなんです
幸福じゃないんです 捨てることで現れる解放感
捨てたらあの解放感 あの自由
あの安らぎ 幸福です 見解ある限り難しいんだけど
まあこういう風に思ってください
家にある生ゴミ 今日も私は捨ててきましたからね
家にたくさん生ゴミ溜まってるでしょ
それは何の躊躇もなく
ゴミが出す日で あれを結んでポイと入れてるでしょ
あの瞬間で捨てるでしょ
気持ち悪く悪い あの解放感なんです
全て捨てたらどうですかね
生ゴミを捨てるだけでも
なんとなく気分がいいんです
捨てることなので 守る必要もも消えたら困るという心配はありません
お釈迦様が我々に立ちなさい
立つ 立ちなさいではない
なりなさいと言っている幸福は捨てることで成り立つんです
だから幸福を守らなくてはではないんです
一旦仏教を学んで幸福になったんだけど
後であの幸福なくなったとはならないんです
なくなる幸せっていうのは
何か捕まっている時だけなんです
例えば やっと金を貯まって旅行に行って
すごいいい旅館にすごい高級旅館に泊まったと
1 日だけで幸福でしょ
でもなくなりますね その幸福は
なぜならば あれ 執着から生まれた幸福だからなんです
捨てることから捨てて得たものだから
もうなくなる恐れがないんです
他の人の見解を理解することも
見解の間違いも見えるのです
そこですべての見解を捨てた人
すべての意見を捨てた人にとっては
人の意見を理解できます
自分が意見を持っている限り
相手の意見は理解できません
例えば 皆様方は日本人だという見解を持っているでしょ
日本人であるという見解を持っている限り
西洋人って何者かと理解できないんです
どう理解して立っても日本人に見える西洋人なんです
だから西洋人で何人かと知りたくなれば
日本人であることを捨てなくちゃあかんですよ
簡単に捨てられますよ
人間ですからね 日本人じゃないんだからね
人間で見てください 西洋人も人間なんです
そうすると あ なるほど
手に取ったようにわかるんです
やっていることは そんなに難しいことではないんです
そこで見解を捨てることで
人の見解は理解できる
その見解の間違いも見えてくる
ということで結構いいんです
心は汚れなくなります
すべて無常だから汚れませんよ
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみが無常に逆らった感情なんです
欲も無常に逆らっているから生まれているんです
本当は心に煩悩が現れるはずがないんです
ではしごのたとえ これも仏教にもあります
横木を離して進むことははしごの使い方です
横木をぎゅっと握ったらはしごではないでしょう
究極の幸福にかけたはしごは
釈尊に説かれた観察の実践です
これでいいということではありません
怯えて震えて横木に横木を握りしめている人には成長はありません
究極の幸福にはしごをかかってます
仏道という観察という握りしめたらダメなんです
握りしめるんだけど 離さなくちゃあかんです
質の悪い見解を捨てて
より良い見解になって
それを捨ててさらに上に行きます
そうやって見解も破って破って
破ったら新たな見解が生まれますけど
それも破って 新たなそれも破って
そうやってより良い より良い見解まで行って
最後の見解も捨てます
苦難に満ちた世界に仏道というはしごを立てています
最後の横木を捨てる捨てたところに解脱という究極の幸福があります
見解を捨てて仏道を歩むと
ブッダに説かれた真理に納得するが
それも見解になります
修行を始めると 世間の言葉は間違っているんだと
ブッダは本当に地球が丸いというような真理を教えたんではないかと納得いくんです
でもそれも見解です 無常苦無我という真理も
頭で知っている限りでは 1種の見解です
無常苦無我は頭でわかったらそれも見解になるんです
捨てることの感性 俗世間的な見解を捨てる人は
如来に説かれた真理に納得します
しかし それも見解になるので執着が起きます
その人にも守る問題があります
その執着も捨て捨てられたら解脱です
ブッダの教えも捨てなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
仏法をいかだにたとえています
いかだを使って輪廻という激流を渡ります
渡った人にはいかだもいりません
捨てる勇気を持ちましょう
見解と自我の錯覚が一体になるので
生半可な気持ちでは捨てることはできません
勇気が必要です しかし
執着は不幸の苦しみの原因であると理解して
捨てる勇気を持てるようにしますと
で これは結論です ということで終了です
どうしました ありがとうございます
もう時間ないね はい はい
質問の時間はものの見事に無くなりました
皆様は損するんだけど
私は得しました はい 今日の講演
説法はね 戸田千秋さんのお布施で成り立ったので
お寺で忙しくて今日は来ていないみたいですけどね
まあそれでも参謀のご覚悟がありますように
幸福になりますようにと請願いたします
皆様にも幸福が訪れますように請願いたします
最後に皆様これ唱えましょう
このお祈りの文句 で 私と一緒に唱えてみてください
まずパーリ語で ドゥッカッパッタチェニン ドゥッカ
バヤンパンタチェニン バヤ
ソーカンパンタチェニッソーカ
ホントゥサンビーピパーニノー
もう一回 ドゥッカッパッタチェニン ドゥッカ
バヤンパンタチェニン バヤ
ソーカンパンタチェニッソーカ
ホントゥサンビーピパーニノー
日本語も言いましょう
苦しんでいる悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]